one and only Gail King let's hit the
headlines again okay
all right
first off a woman accorded to Insider
the unusual way she calmed her nerves
before a first kiss so she was flying
across country to meet a man that she'd
been in a long distance relationship or
dating with for a month but they hadn't
yet physically connected so I've Never
Been Kissed if you will I will
[Applause]
we all know what it's like to anticipate
a kiss and she was anticipating and she
was like where is it gonna happen when
is it gonna happen
um you know it got just really
overwhelming for her so she sent this
guy a Google invite on the calendar
titled first kiss and scheduled it for
when she landed at the airport there's
even a two-minute window if you notice
it says 10 15 to 10 17.
I'm Gail Ross thoughts love you love
this yes I do are you out of your mind
schedule the first kiss you know what I
would schedule what a return flight
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no no no no no
you are so wrong about this number one
you were so wrong rossly Ross
as you said the anticipation is building
they've been talking online and so
they've had no physical contact and you
just want to take the weight out of
when's it going to happen how's it going
to happen What do we do how do we do so
I actually think it's cute and I think
it's very creative but that tense moment
of when's it going to happen and the
passion has been removed by the Google
Calendar okay this she's taken it all
out she's removed that that moment Gail
where at any moment I could just let me
say this I could just grab you and kiss
you okay I said it okay and it could
happen to anybody but if you schedule it
that's okay that tension is gone she
didn't schedule sex raw she just
sketches
is a difference well she started with
the kiss check the calendar because
that's next all right
you never know with this one all right
next up DME science reports an age-old
theory has finally been confirmed I love
this Yes Men Who Drive flashy sports
cars do worry about their size yeah
a study by University College London
told participating men facts about their
average size of a
Johnson yeah okay and um and then showed
them products like cars and other luxury
items and asked them to rate how much
they wanted them and the group that
believed that they're you know was uh
below average rated their desire for
sports cars higher than those who
thought they were doing doing pretty
good down there you know what I mean yes
yeah so it turns out if you if you got a
lot of horsepower in your car you don't
got a lot yeah let's go with you first
what kind of car do you drive how dare
you
[Applause]
like a convertible oh that's a
two-seater oh man
I'm good Gail don't worry about me I'm
good I wasn't worried okay but you
weren't worried you weren't thinking
about it
well I know you are you are right I
think but but this this study though
does make sense to me also tell me well
because I do think that and not all men
but I do think some men uh and I don't
want to generalize but they use it as a
replacement to show listen I'm really
virile I'm really hot I'm really good
I'm really firing in all cylinders and
I'm saying that for everybody sure but I
could see this this study does make
sense to me rays of hands and I'm going
to ask the men here yes do you think
this study is accurate raise your hands
if you think it is
and that doesn't
mean right that doesn't mean anything
about you it's yes we're just saying
about this stuff right yeah you're a
brave man what's your name uh Drew oh
sure to make your acquaintance and why
do you think as a man that the study
tracks um I just feel like it's kind of
like what you're attracted to right when
you're looking at cars like you're like
I need to prove my masculinity you're
attracted to a car like that usually so
thank you Drew Drew you didn't say what
you thought
I am pretty dubious especially also uh
the loudness also gives a Telltale sign
like when a guy's on a Harley that
literally will burst your eardrums I'm
thinking oh there is nothing down there
because
I don't know why you're trying to beat
up my eardrums to prove your masculinity
but this is taking like all of us down
[Applause]
and I just I think you know I've always
worried about men who Flash and I don't
mean that kind of flash I mean what's
the what's the word for it like they the
chest yeah yeah
who are very showy yeah yeah like I I I
think I want a like here's a great quote
that totally
um applies to this which is
um insecurity is loud confidence is
quiet
so I apply that I like to that should be
a car advertising yeah
[Applause]
I like that well if if you were to meet
a man Gail what would your dream car for
him be well I like a big car oh
but I do I like big cars big men big
dogs I just like big and because I'm a
big girl so a little two-seaters I I
don't feel safe in those so
and uh
uh if you had a big dog I would be so
happy I love dogs I love dogs I like but
I'm not going to judge you by your car
yeah I don't think I see the size of
your car I'm not going to judge you by
that yeah I don't think I'm gonna We're
not gonna end up together because I got
a little convertible and little
chihuahuas
otherwise we're a perfect match and Ross
you have a husband oh death married men
that too
Gail not my husband last night
[Applause]
's airs weekdays at 7 A.M on CBS and up
next the secret to cutting down on your
phone time and other things that you
gotta try this weekend
[Music]